feeling good leads to success but why I
wondered the more I read the more I
realized that the explanations are
varied and in some cases remain unclear
but scientists have started to home in
on a few answers first feeling good
boosts our energy when we feel good we
generate energy which boosts our
productivity and this productivity leads
to feelings of achievement which make us
feel good all over again second feeling
good reduces our stress that positive
emotions can undo the effects of stress
and other negative emotions if stress is
the problem then feeling good might just
be the solution but the final and most
transformative implication of Feelgood
productivity goes well beyond any one
task or project because third feeling
good enriches your life individuals who
frequently experience positive emotions
aren't just more sociable optimistic and
creative they also accomplish more these
people bring an infectious energy to
their environment proving more likely to
enjoy fulfilling relationships get
higher salaries and truly shine in their
professional
lives